.
>> Sean: I APPRECIATE YOU,
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR SERVICE.
NOW THE STATION CHIEF, FORMER
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
NEWT GINGRICH, BOTH FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR'S, THERE IS A CLEAR
DISTINCTION, THE TRUMP PLANET
WAS GOING TO BE BASED ON
CONDITIONS ON THE GROUND, FACTOR
NUMBER ONE.
FACTOR NUMBER TWO IS
DONALD TRUMP WAS BELIEVED.
DONALD TRUMP MADE A THREAT, THEY
BELIEVED IT BECAUSE HE HAD A
TRACK RECORD WHILE ISIS GREW
UNDER BIDEN AND OBAMA, ISIS WAS
SYSTEMATICALLY DESTROYED UNDER
DONALD TRUMP.
HE SAID IT ENDED IT ON THE
TALIBAN NEW WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
THEY DIDN'T ABIDE BY ANY
AGREEMENT THAT WENT ON.
THEY WOULDN'T HAVE TRIED THIS
UNDER TRUMP WOULD BE MY
ARGUMENT.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I DON'T KNOW
THAT JOE BIDEN HAS THREATENED
ANYBODY WITH ANYTHING.
THERE IS NO WAY OF KNOWING.
IT SEEMS TO BE TO ATTACK YOUR
ALLIES, YOU KNOW YOUR ENEMIES,
PRETEND THAT BAD THINGS AREN'T
HAPPENING.
I WATCHED THE SPEECH THIS
AFTERNOON AND FOR MOST PEOPLE IF
YOU TOOK WHAT YOU WERE SEEING
LIVE COMING OUT OF AFGHANISTAN
OF THE CROWDS AND THE FEAR, THE
TAKEOVER BY THE TABLET BAND AND
THEN YOU LOOKED AT THE SPEECH BY
THIS GUY WHO WAS CLEARLY TOTALLY
OUT OF IT, HAS NO IDEA WHAT'S
GOING ON AND HIS NUMBER ONE GOAL
IN THAT SPEECH WAS TO BLAME
ANYONE ELSE, HE SAID THE BUCK
STOPS HERE.
HE DIDN'T MEAN THAT.
IT STOPS WITH THE AFGHAN ARMY,
STOPS WITH DONALD TRUMP, BUT THE
FACT IS THIS IS A MAJOR AMERICAN
DEFEAT THAT IS GOING TO HAVE
HUGE CONSEQUENCES AS YOU POINTED
OUT EARLIER, GOING TO EMBOLDEN
THE CHINESE WHETHER IT'S IN
TAIWAN WITH THE SOUTH CHINA SEA
OR THEY'RE GOING TO BECOME
ALLIES OF THE TALIBAN.
BECAUSE THEY WANT THE MINERALS
IN WHICH NORTHERN AFGHANISTAN IS
ENORMOUSLY RICH AND THEY WILL BE
QUITE HAPPY.
THEY DON'T CARE WHAT THE TALIBAN
DOES TO WOMEN.
THEY JUST WANT THE MINERALS.
>> Sean: AS RECENTLY AS LAST
THURSDAY AND YOU WORKED ALL
THESE YEARS AND THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY, THEY WERE TELLING US
THEY WOULDN'T MAKE IT THERE FOR
ANOTHER 90 DAYS AT LEAST.
ON EVERY LEVEL, HOW COULD THEY
HAVE BEEN SO WRONG?
HOW COULD JOE BIDEN JUST A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO BE SAYING IT
WILL NEVER HAPPEN, THE TALIBAN
WILL NEVER BE ABLE TO GET BACK
IN POWER AND NOW IT IS THE
EMIRATES OF AFGHANISTAN, HERE WE
GO.
ISLAMIC EMIRATES OF AFGHANISTAN.
>> IT IS ASPIRATIONAL, WISHFUL
FOREIGN POLICY JUST AS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WAS ARGUING THEY
WANTED TO LET THEY WANTED TO
TAKE OVER THE COUNTRY BY FORCE
BUT THAT IGNORED THE REALITY
THAT CHINA AND RUSSIA OUR
GREATEST ALLY WAS A FORMER
GOVERNMENT OF AFGHANISTAN AND
WHAT REALLY CONCERNS ME GOING
FORWARD IS THEY USED TO OWN AND
THEY HAD A SIZABLE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY FOOTPRINTS WHEN WE
SERVED OUR MISSION TO FIND AND
FIX THOSE SO WE COULD PROTECT
AND PREEMPT THREATS, WE HAD AN
ABILITY TO PREEMPT THEM.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT ANYMORE AND
THE TELL THE BAND CONTROLS THE
COUNTRY SO WHAT I WANTED TO HEAR
TODAY AND I HOPE WE HEAR SOON,
WHAT'S THE PLAN TO DO WITH THOSE
THREATS?
IRONY OF IRONIES, AT GREATER
RISK OF AFGHANISTAN THAN WE EVER
HAVE BEEN BEFORE.
>> Sean: MR. SPEAKER, WE HAVE
10,000 AMERICANS THERE AND NOT
CONTROL OF THE COUNTRY OR THAT
AIRPORT.
HOW DO THEY GET THOSE AMERICANS
HOME?
>> IT'S VERY DISTURBING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION YESTERDAY
WOULDN'T BE AUTOMATICALLY GIVEN
ANY KIND OF PRIORITY WHICH IS
THE OPPOSITE OF THE POLICY WE'VE
ALWAYS HAD UP UNTIL NOW.
I THINK THERE'S A DEEPER THING
HERE.
BEEN AROUND FOR A LONG TIME.
A SET OF GOALS, A RELIGIOUS
FANATIC GROUP.
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN TO WOMEN
AND PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH WAS
EXACTLY RIGHT TODAY, THE
GREATEST THING HE FEARS IS
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN TO YOUNG
GIRLS AND WOMEN.
AT A YOUNG WOMAN FROM IRAQ WHO
HAD BEEN CAPTURED BY ISIS AND
HAD BASICALLY PASSED AROUND AS
A, THAT'S THE KIND OF STUFF THEY
SEE IN AFGHANISTAN AND NOT A
SINGLE WOMEN'S GROUP ON THE LEFT
IS UP IN ARMS OVER WHAT'S ABOUT
TO HAPPEN.
>> Sean: WE